Vsauce! We finally have spreadable beer. It's
a collaboration between an Italian chocolate
maker and an Italian brewer and can spread
on toast or really anything you want. There's
a dark ale and a golden ale version and it's
already so popular that this sweet or savor
beer spread is currently out of stock.
Japan has solved the problem of body odor
by chewing. Otoko kaoru gum which translates
to "man smell" doesn't make you smell like
a man, it makes your sweat smell like roses
because the rose essence from the gum gets
released through your pores.
Le Whif is a French product that let's you
inhale chocolate. You get the same sensation
as eating it without all of the calories.
Their motto is as sweet as chocolate, as light
as air. It also comes in raspberry, mint,
and coffee which has the caffeine equivalent
as a shot of espresso.
For adults who aren't scared of calories CREAM
makes flavored whipped cream infused with
alcohol. It comes in raspberry, vanilla, chocolate,
cherry, and caramel and each flavor is 30
proof. Their website even gives you recipes
to follow instead of just straight up eating
this stuff.
If you prefer something kinda weird and salty
try there's always bobs pickle pops. It's
pickle juice..... in a plastic container....that
you can drink..... at room temperature or
frozen. And they're claiming to be finally
uniting closet pickle juice drinkers from
around the world.
Blue cheese flavored lollipops. Lollyphile,
a website full of interesting lollipop flavors
offers these for $10 a pop and say they are
delicious.... and if you don't think so you
can order one of the absinthe pops and probably
forget it ever happened.
And then there's sushi pop. It's literally
a push pop for sushi so you can enjoy California
rolls, cucumber rolls, and spicy shrimp rolls
on the go! Also have a pretty amazing jingle.
In order to save space in refrigerators japan
starting making cube-shaped watermelons. They
are much more expensive than the regular old
oval ones, but very convenient. They even
come in heart, face, and pyramid shapes. Check
out this Do it Yourself project on Instructables
on how to grow your own cube shaped watermelon!
Wash all of those delicious treats down with
Pig placenta juice from Japan which apparently
tastes like peaches and not placenta. Not
that I would know what that tastes like....peaches
I mean.
And as always... thanks for watching.